turning down to France where president
Emmanuel macron has invoked
extraordinary powers to bypass the lower
house of Parliament and force through a
plan to raise the country's official
retirement age the move was met with
anger on the streets and that's putting
it lightly where thousands of people
took part in demonstrations Elaine Cobb
has more from Paris
police clashed with protesters as angry
workers took to the streets within
minutes of the government forcing
through unpopular pension reforms they
will see the retirement age raised from
62 to 64 which is still younger than
most of Europe
opposition lawmakers booed and jeered as
prime minister Elizabeth Bourne told the
National Assembly where the bill would
not pass she was invoking special
Constitutional Powers to force the bill
through as it became clear the minority
government did not have the support to
win the planned vote they sang the
national anthem to drown her out as she
told them we cannot gamble on the future
of our pensions this reform is necessary
president Emmanuel macron says his
reforms are needed to ensure today's
young people have a pension when they
retire and without having to fund it by
raising taxes his plans prompted
Nationwide strikes and protests from
January they caused transport chaos
closed schools
this man says we are the ones who have
to work another two years we are the
ones dying on the job we are the ones
dying unemployed so at the end of the
day it's up to us to decide and a nearly
two-week-old strike by trash collectors
has left piles of garbage heaped around
Paris
as night fell some protesters lost no
time setting them on fire the unions
have called for stepped up strikes and
more protests they say they won't stop
until the reforms are dropped altogether
for CBS mornings Elaine Cobb Paris